laughs
hello everyone
welcome
let's just let's make
because yesterday
some people didn't know what we were
doing so how about today
will like make this slightly higher
we'll make this slightly lower
and
task
make fake users
for diva
that's it
all right
so I guess we need to make it a bit
smaller
uh
nope
stop
it's really hard to select this
there we go nice okay
make it a bit smaller
all right
that should do
while we're at it we can make this thing
a bit more like this
cool
that handled
nice hello chat So today we're going to
continue on the open assistant oh no I
don't want code spaces
um
the open Assistant it's a project that's
aiming to replicate chat GPT in an open
source manner so we're going to try to
do this uh now obviously the biggest
part of the work is the data collection
but before that we have to code all the
systems that allow us to do the data
collection uh if you want to participate
this is the repository it's fully open
everyone's welcome to participate
there's also a project board right here
where you can see a little bit what's
going on
um so
there is a backlog there is a to-do list
if you are interested I guess you can
just whatever isn't to do and is not
assigned that's super duper free to do
to to make
um so here to do it not assigned
if you want something large if you want
something medium there's also By
Priority uh yeah just have a go
I'm interested to watch this but I have
to work uh it's not gonna be it's I've
if I don't do something stupid I can
leave it up
yesterday I didn't I didn't dream like I
have to consciously pay attention
whether I do something dumb or not and
then I I can leave it up if it's if it's
nothing dumb so
um yeah if you're interested there's to
do it not assigned that's ordered by
size that it's mostly what I think how
big the task is or By Priority here you
can also look at the at the tags that
are assigned whether you'd like to
contribute in research manners in
website in data collection and so on and
you're also
a very welcome to obviously
um
suggest more things also here we have we
have in Discord there's Channel called
open Assistant where you're free to
discuss things there's also one on the
lion Discord that also discusses this
recap what we did last time so yesterday
um we went through and we made it such
that there is an end point for users to
send
um to send text labels now maybe I have
to explain the bigger the bigger picture
a little bit
so the bigger picture is we want to
collect data and I think that's visible
here on the repository you can see we
want to collect data and and the plan is
essentially to follow instruct GPT as a
system so first we want to create human
generated instruction fulfillment which
means essentially the humans play both
the users and the assistant right so so
here it says prompt plus response but we
can also make that multi-step prompt
response interactions uh
and therefore we need to collect the
state second of all we will rank
assistant outputs and human outputs and
then train a reward model and then third
we do the reinforcement learning from
Human feedback uh the vision is also
here we want to go further than that we
want to provide essentially the open
source assistant that people can build
upon integrate with and so on I think
that'd be really cool it'd be really
cool if that were open and if we didn't
all have to pay open AI to do it uh
because that's kind of
dumb and you will never be able to get
it to do something interesting because
it will deny almost everything
because it's too spicy
now
as I said we are we're still in this
phase right here so we want to collect
this training data what we actually want
to do is we want to train uh we want to
create the Discord bot and a website
that that would these things we call
front ends that the user can interact
with what does that mean it means that
we send the user a task and the task
could just be please provide a prompt
and the prompt is just something you
would ask the assistant hey assistant
write an email that contains this and
this hey assistant uh what was the I
don't know what was the 60th president
of some country hey assistant you know
something like this
um
or the task could be please reply as an
assistant so in that case we take one of
the prompts that was you know given by
the user
by users before you and we will present
it to you and you will be able to answer
as the assistant and in the and we can
go on we can take a prompt that was
given by a user an assistant reply that
was given by a user and then we can
create those two things which
essentially form a thread and then we
can add a user reply behind that like we
can ask the user what would you as a
user now reply to that interaction with
the assistant maybe you're happy maybe
you want to clarify some things and so
on so that's that all the while you know
if we present the same thing to multiple
users we'll get multiple answers we'll
get multiple responses from someone
playing the assistant will get multiple
continuations that we can also use to
rank so we can ask the human hey here
are three things that other humans
responded in response to this prompt
which one do you think is best then that
we can and directly use that either to
moderate data to filter out spam and so
on or to go ahead and train this reward
model that we're going to need later
like in step two we can collect all this
data so
our lhf is reinforcement learning from
Human feedback so
this here this repository is essentially
the attempt that we have a back end and
the back end does almost everything in
terms of logic so it decides what tasks
to give and how to collect data and so
on the front ends are responsible for
rendering that the data and whatever the
back end gives so today what we're going
to try to do is to make it such that the
website at least so the Discord pod is a
bit harder to develop but the website
here such that that can accept fake
users so every front end is tasked with
authenticating its users now obviously a
Discord bot already has that being done
by Discord a website needs to do that
itself so today for debugging purposes
we're going to try to make it such that
we can essentially activate debug mode
and there's always going to be a set of
users present that I can just use from
the beginning now I have no idea how
we're going to do that I just thought of
this task I thought it might make life
easier for a lot of people so yeah the
first thing I actually want to do is to
create an issue for myself to solve
um
so new issue create
a set of
fake default users
yeah for the website
during and
it's often useful to have debug users
that just exist
out
first needing to register
this would make
development
easier for newcomers
as they could just flip a flag and
not worry about the registration
workflow
all right do we give it some labels so
the label it's a feature that concerns
the website
um we'll add it to our project
uh the Milestone I don't think that's
contained in the minimum viable
prototype Milestone but you know so here
that goes into the in progress will
estimate it has a medium priority and we
should be done in one to four hours
which is going to be this live stream
sign myself
and we're good to go alright there we go
now we make a branch for it so if you
want to contribute
then select an issue or make an issue or
tell us and we'll make an issue and then
comment if you would like to to take
something it's best to comment with like
a short plan of what you want to do
um that's like that's super and it's
super clear right if you're in the on
the right track and so on it prevents
people from doing work that is you know
in a bit in the wrong direction or
Superfluous or something like this if
you first write a bit of a plan
um then
yeah but right now obviously since I
made the issue I I I don't need to do
that but
um if someone else makes the issue it
first communicate a little bit of a plan
of how to solve it in this case I would
just create the branch right here for
that
um create the branch
copy the name of the branch switch over
to vs code
git Fetch and then let's switch to that
Branch I'll make the font size it's
difficult to cram everything here on one
screen but we're going to try try to do
that
all right so
we'll check out that branch
all right
so
if we want to develop in you work in the
website
um
it's probably good if we just open a bit
of a terminal
get
and start ourselves an environment now
this is still called open chat GPT but
we've renamed it since to open Assistant
because it's a cooler name it's less
um it's less sort of related to open AI
because they weren't so nice to to Dolly
mini well I guess I don't know if they
weren't so nice but they had problems
with Dolly Mini
uh
we get a thought of using user stories
As an X I want to do y so that I can see
the description of a task yeah why not
that could be a cool I think the
software engineering workflow is really
like a good example for
um is a good example for how we
initially would like to interact with
these assistants right will this stream
be available on the channel if I don't
say or do something stupid I'll leave it
up
so count bet on me
as far as you know you cannot make
Jackie read information from websites
until you directly provide data
chat GPT yes exactly but our assistant
could do that
um that's the that's the cool thing
right we don't have to wait for openai
to do anything we just go ahead and do
it if we feel now we want to make the
assistant browse the web for something
we can just make it do that and we have
lots of ideas of doing these kinds of
things so don't don't worry
um I predict this will take you guys
four years well so yeah I have four
years I mean
yeah
not if we get some help right
um but we should get to like an MVP
really quick and I think you know the
the beauty of Open Source is that as
people contribute to it
um and see that there's momentum uh it
it attracts a lot of a lot of influx of
work so I think we can really push this
and accelerate this and provide
essentially
provide an assistant to everyone right
this is this could be the the Linux of
assistance
or yeah I'm not sure what the what the
good analogy is
um
yeah what are the ethical limitations
you're not you're not allowed to take
the source code put it on a floppy disk
and hit someone with it you're not
allowed the license explicitly
explicitly for uh for bits then
why not make a code editor that uses
pre-trained templates for the ad to
generate code what you want codex to
make a bulk of code copilot basically
check it and lay it out
um yes there are ideas of doing that
there's a bit of a question with respect
to the viability in terms of the
legality so a lot of these open AI apis
forbid you from using their output as
like training code and so on but you
could use it potentially as in context
learning or something like this
um
yeah
open Siri
yeah it's like a Siri that actually
works
cool all right now enough talking if we
want to develop
the website right so we have a bunch of
in this scripts folder here we have a
bunch of different different
um
stuff
so if we want to develop the website
um we are developing a what's called a
front end so the back end is doing the
the whole work in in terms of data
collection and so on and I was gonna do
an issue in the back end but a Community
member uh thankfully like Grace
gracefully took took that issue which is
really important so that's pretty cool
so now I'm doing something on the front
end so I want to go to this front-end
development folder right here now there
is a readme that is fairly simple
um
so here we just Docker compose up if we
look at the
Docker compose thing well my my neovim
is absolutely broken
um but if we look at the docker compose
it spins up a database and it's been
something database for the website it
spins up the back end
um it doesn't check API keys
since we're debugging it spins up a mail
server that we might need and then we
can spin up the website against that so
um Docker compose up build
and we should be good to go
should you not use something like Key
Club to manage I am yeah so it's a it's
a bit it's a bit tricky we oh
we don't wanna necessarily authenticate
the users in the back end that would be
like a giant amount of work and if we
have a Discord bot already and and
especially if the website uses Discord
oauth
super easy
um
so the authentication is essentially
done for us but yeah it would be there
there be more sophisticated Solutions
but for right now I just want a bunch of
fake users for debugging
will it always be truthful if I'm fat
but I want it to tell me I look great
will I be able to do this if it if it is
a competent assistant they will be able
to do that yes it there's no like if you
hire
if you hire a human assistant there is
no you know law that says that they must
be truthful obviously be good if they
were but if you instruct an employee to
tell you that you're you're handsome and
slim even though you're very you're
clearly not then I think most humans
would would uh would do that
um and just say it's part of their job
but yeah
that I guess is is a it's not really a
machine discussion it's more like a
discussion of what
what would you want
I think it'd certainly be capable of
doing that
and I will not build anything into it
that uh would prevent you from
instructing you would prevent you from
instructing it to do that all right so
we're currently
bringing up the the docker compose
environment I am using a Mac with an
Intel chip because it's a bit older so
my hands are nice and warm all the time
and it's Breathing heavily
foreign
yeah so all the while we should probably
um add a second tab right here
and that could run the website itself
yes you can see that with Docker and OBS
streaming uh this it's it's it's coming
quite to its limits in what it can do
let me just close a few other things let
me bring up this
foreign
it's not easy being a
being a MacBook
with an Intel chip
all right that's about that's about what
I can do
cool
um yes Docker build is going on
website npm run Dev I believe I believe
let's try
we can try
all right
disable the video preview for obs
how I do that View
how to do that
Docs
profile scene tools
right click on the video that that is
okay enable preview nice cool thank you
all right so this is the website
currently
um no it's not live anywhere yet but
we're on it look it even has cool
animation I've I have not developed this
so that's why it looks good
look at this gradient this is so cool
um yeah so
um if I log in right here
then something should happen
so I can
um
register with my email address so let's
say test at test.com continue
and what happens what happens in the
background there is a big fat error
that's always good to know get user by
email error error error find unique nope
nope
website does not exist
the database does not exist ah there we
go
Port is already allocate oh everything's
failing all right so let's grab all the
docker containers and delete them
let's try to spin them up again
and I'm not sure what the default values
here are for the for the npm thing
is there even
can I just start this or
I probably need to do some some kind of
Prisma push
um
luckily there's readme's
yep
all right provides
initially it will support this
contributing the website is built using
npm
good
to contribute the following setup good
node version manager yes
Docker yes getting everything up and
running this is so easy
how do you plan to create the default
users I I will have a flag
that you can activate that essentially
says a debug fake users
and if you do that it will just when you
try to log in with the fake user it will
just accept you
um
that's the plan
I want I want to bypass if possible the
database for this although it might not
be possible because later we might need
database entries for users to be present
um yeah why is it that you don't use the
terminal in vs code because if I have
the terminal here
um
then there's almost nothing left of the
coding screen
so that there that's it's just it's just
a bit small if you like
because of the stream and the font size
um
yeah so
navigate to front-end development yes
yes website npm install this one we need
this one
so we'll first try to make a user right
and the the other
the other possibility would also be to
just make a little script that makes the
um default user just creates it does the
registration for you but we'll see
so
um run Dev did you start this project I
I'd say so among like with other people
together I'm not the I'm not like the
the sole founder of this
um but I have pushed strongly and I am
now coordinating efforts
the DB init file could create the user
doesn't it yes but I only want to want
it to do it uh at like debug time so if
we actually deploy this the this user
shouldn't be created
the task text is in front of the
terminal prompt for us that's true
I'm not exactly sure I should do about
this because the window manager sort of
forces me and there's the dock down here
the window manager kind of forces me to
see I can all I can do is I can like
scroll up for you
I'm sorry
I guess I could do that
take that down a notch
put it up here
like this
okay so we're good
um
yes let's try that again
refresh this page
test at test.com
okay
so if I press enter
nothing happens
which is probably the first thing we
could we could fix right
actually let me make an issue if one of
you wants to contribute
um
if I press I'm pretty sure if I press
enter here I should
it should submit the form
this is an easy one to fix no
[Music]
um
sign
sign up form should submit on Enter key
make a screenshot
this screen here
does not
at this screen here
[ __ ]
I'm wondering how we can improve the
didn't you want to do all off via docker
um
yeah we we're event we're going to have
Discord authentication uh but
we also want to support email but this
chord should be should be the main one
just so this is a bug website
um
this that
to do
it's tiny and it has medium priority
good
um yeah
are you going to deploy the database via
Docker and Docker compose in debug yeah
it's a Docker compose in actual let's
say prod right now it's an ansible
Playbook that deploys a Docker container
people who join in the middle have no
idea what's going on that's true that's
the good thing about Minecraft right uh
you can join at any time you know what's
going on
um sign in link has been sent to your
email address so that should be
somewhere here in the logs
let's see let's see
fatal no running upgrade
checkpoint complete
what do we do
database does not exist
yada yada
well that doesn't sound too good
honestly
um yeah let's actually see whether or
not the
um
yeah that doesn't sound too good
foreign
verify
maybe a pinned comment in live chat
saying what's going on
yeah that's what the the little the
black messages or the white message on
the black thing is for but yeah I see
it's not it's not super might not be the
most helpful
um
all right we need to check whether
everything is even connected correctly
so let's go over to the website
um
and
I have a Docker file we should probably
get back to the readme
read me and see whether the environment
variables line up correctly
hmm
okay database configurations are stored
in Prisma let's look there
Prisma schema
here
provider
so there's an environment variable
called database
URL
the question is where is it so in the N
file right here we see the database URL
concerns a
postgres
um
user a postgres
[Music]
password and an ocgpt website database
now
I think in the docker compose that's
different
um
compose in the front end
we're having a
webdb
probably makes the default database
which is called postgres as well right
that's not too good
and then
the end to end demo
database
oh c
so I think I did that wrong and I think
this here should have
postgres user postgres password
see what co-pilot says here
postgres DB yes exactly exactly so let's
have that
let's have this
and
let's copy
here
this one
um
like this
I hope that works no no thank you
Marketplace
go back
cancel it stopping stop stop it
down and up
topic why are you not on mlst lately
because I have too much stuff to do
and I'm not needed as much there
because
I don't know whenever topics come back
up where I'm more useful I I guess I'll
they will invite me more
but I'm more like a
a uh
a frequent guest
so I'm I'm getting called
up I'm getting called whenever need
arises like Batman
except I
I fight the bad opinions and and not
criminals
what is the model that's behind open
assistant how does it compare to gpt3
there's no model yet
um so the goal for open assistant is
that at least there is a variant of it
that always runs on
um consumer Hardware
that's really important because I think
everybody should have access to it and
that also means that it should be
reasonably possible to run the thing on
your own Hardware or at least something
that you can like pay or you know with
not you don't need a super cluster to
run it that brings some limitations but
I think it's worth it
um to to trade that to tr to do the
trade-off
so as I said we don't know yet exactly
what but we're pretty sure that it's
going to be awesome
um manage Docker containers from vs code
yes that's true I'm I'm not super
familiar with vs code yet I'm just
migrating from from neovim
isn't the debug skip API key check what
you're trying to do no the API key check
um it checks whether or not the front
end sends a valid API key to the back
end it skips that which is useful for
debugging to skip that however what
we're trying to do right now is to
essentially skip the need to create a
user in the front end
so let's try that again I'm gonna try to
log in so this is the this is the sign
this is also a bit of a
um
like just the user experience here it
says log in right and then I get I come
I come to the sign up page where is if I
want to log in
I need to go
here which which doesn't work yet uh but
I click on login and it's sign up but
Minor Detail minor detail
all right so
let's see whether now
actually something happened
um
not here
how about here
did we send out an email
no
we did not
attempting to upgrade alembic at stardom
see I've never worked with the with the
front end
what's your view and contrastive search
for text generation makes the 300M
generation scooters 175b model
generation yes search is needed in in
generation so if I I don't see this this
whole ooh chat GPT will replace Google
as a search engine it's I see the the
language models as essentially the
equivalent to to humans or not
equivalent to humans but you know they
kind of absorb information and they
build like some latent representation
and they can recall bits and pieces they
can interpolate so they know something
quote unquote right from their memories
but it's not like they have
The Source information at hand when they
produce text
on the other hand Google for example has
the source information perfectly
available yet they can't interpolate
that well so humans are super productive
when they are augmented by a search
engine therefore I don't see why
um you know therefore it should be
possible to augment the language models
with the search engine and make them
super duper powerful so I strongly
believe in that and um if open assistant
ever
um
gets off the ground works you know we
will build in a retrieval component
definitely because that's it's just too
powerful to ignore
all right we are going to debug what's
going on right here
um
we're going to debug why things aren't
happening that's why we go to here
website where we have Source I could
probably read in the readme but I never
read instructions that's for that's for
boring people
sign up okay so here we have the sign in
form
um this calls this sign-in function
um
next that's directly from oh that's
directly from next off uh sign in
sign in
token provider
sign in with email
element current value that probably will
get the email address that I typed in
yes there's a ref on there
um
AI plus source is op
it'll be the non-restricted open source
AI like chat chip yes exactly
it could even make search better it
could definitely make search better yes
AI plus Source yes obviously
um
source code is a good medium to trans to
communicate from humans to machines we
knew that already but it just been it's
just been like one way so far just been
that the humans communicate to the
machines like the instructions but I
think even as like a two-way
communication is probably pretty good
um and machines interacting with other
machines source code is also really good
isn't sticky Anonymous user would be
more stickier
uh I get I I guess but that sort of
isn't that sort of tracking so wait
let's let's focus
sign up yes email
sign in with email should not
jsx props should not use arrow is this
Arrow this is Arrow
well I don't care what I should or
shouldn't do you can't tell me what to
do
um
so this is the email provider
I
just want to see what's going on here
let's put in a debugger
let's open the console
and
let's do this
and we can also go back to the readme
and see whether there's something here
to help us to create an account log in
via the user email Authentication
yes
navigate to check the email oh oh see
see I'm I knew I'm stupid
localhost 1080.
that's the mail server ha okay
it worked
wow
insane
do you know whether or not code that
you've gotten portions from chat GB
requires a license the model seems to be
hallucinating every time if I ask if it
wants credits
something if I was to publish the code
on GitHub sometimes it says use GPA
license other times to use MIT license
it's a it's an ongoing question so
I'm not I'm not sure of the I'm not a
lawyer right this is not legal advice
I'm not sure of the considerations there
um
for certain chat GPT
may may
just one-to-one copy paste code that is
somewhere on GitHub right
if it outputs that
and that code is whatever GPL license
it's most clear if it's patented if it's
patented
um you like don't like you're you're in
the wrong posting that you may be
slapped with with a fee or royalties or
a lawsuit again not a lawyer
um if it has a copyright
um you may be subject to copyright
because that is a creative work by
another author and they control the
means by which it is reproduced
therefore you posting that code on
GitHub is
not okay even if chat GPT wrote it at
least as far as I understand it now it
gets murky it gets murky when it comes
to well what if GPT just kind of is
inspired by that code and doesn't
exactly reproduce it but changes it a
little that's a complete gray area as a
human you're perfectly allowed to look
at other people's source code and then
essentially be inspired by it and do it
in your own way so what's protected
under copyright is often just the
expression of a creative idea not the
idea itself
but as I said there are many
considerations here and I'm I'm by no
means yeah a lawyer so
good we are logged in essentially is
look this is our user sign out
we are now signed out login
I have an account I want to log in so we
we don't even have a login page yet
right
okay you want GPT J probably
I want GPT 4chan to be the base model
yes yes I'm sure that will I'm sure that
will be fine I'm sure that will actually
it's pretty useful to be like an
anti-based model so to to just steer or
you know like uh
classifier free guidance to just steer
away from whatever gpd4 channel would
say I'm pretty sure that would even work
okay-ish
um
will yesterday's video be available I
haven't looked through it yet whether
whether it's
it's
whether I did something said something
dumb or not so
if not then we might okay so we config
we we confirmed that works
there is a sign up page there is a
verify page okay
now
sign in sign in with email
I mean I don't know next off that's the
problem
right
um
I don't know next off we'll probably
need to do some research on
next off
will you also be coding the model I
don't know yet I'm
I'm hopefully hopefully not
um I very excited that we there are a
lot of people who who are
um interested in helping here so there's
gonna be
people that are much more capable than
me
um doing these kinds of things and I
hope someone much more competent and
capable than me is going to be involved
with model training but I'll certainly
be
um
I'll certainly be
accompanying it
all right so let's see
we have here we have sign in
using the sign in method ensures the
user ends back page they started or
after completing the sign in flow we'll
also handle crsf tokens if you automatic
for you automatically when signing with
an email csrf sorry cross site something
request portrait I guess I'm not sure
um
sign in method can be called in
different ways
redirects the sign in page when clicked
starts the oauth sign inflow when
clicked
here Google search the email sign inflow
specifying a callback URL we did that
using the redirect false option
okay additional parameters
okay
good
so sign in seems to be
this now
that will just send you an email that's
just a flow it'll send you an email you
click on the email
and
it will go
to the page
no longer valid
sign in
okay
so
that's the the flow I guess what you
could do is then save this into a
database and so on and so forth okay we
don't want to do that necessarily what
we want to do is we simply want to
wait
create some fake users
use session
the easiest way to check if someone is
signed in a session
returns an object containing two values
data and status
loading authenticated unauthenticated
every protected page load has to make
server side requests okay
hmm
configuration no providers
here there's there should be maybe some
local phase wow that's a lot of
providers
overview
using a built-in oauth provider using a
custom using credentials
credentials provided to sign in with
arbitrary credentials such as username
password
why not
next off is f for password login
okay
you need to wrestle the controller out
of this out of the hands of open air I
mean open air is doing cool work but
yeah
no DB session store with credentials
provider ah wait what
okay
that's a bit
let's I will try
we'll try to we'll try to configure a
credentials provider and if it doesn't
work then
um yeah
providers
get providers
is there some kind of configuration file
maybe this maybe here no
um
we'll just search around for it
maybe here
maybe we'll just search for Discord
that seems to be easier
there we go
see
that was easy
you can do it using JWT in the client
okay
um so here we need the credentials Pro
or is JWT that's not a separate provider
right
because that's more like a method of
storing
foreign
can only be used if Json web tokens are
enabled for sessions
all right
I'm starting to think that I'm going to
spend a lot of time here
let's see
and to Hash email verification tokens
session there we go what's this where is
this where's where do I find this file
where do I find this file
session this is like
config options
options
default volume
anyone know where this file is
um
providers
next to auth options probably here no
strategy JWT we're already good we're
already good why why so why so what why
we we're already cool completely cool
all right
foreign
so
let's grab the credentials Provider from
here
good now
let's
here's the Discord provider
okay if process and
um debug
fake users
oh I forgot I forgot go buy that exists
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh I forgot I don't need to code anymore
that is that that surprised me
okay empty block no it's not empty all
right so fake users credentials
mm-hmm
authorize
we're just gonna find
and find it
but I still need to register somehow so
these are still these are found in the
database no
so with the credentials provider I need
to provide
credentials the credentials used to
generate suitable form in the sign in
page you can specify whatever field you
want
okay
um
cool username text placeholder there's
no placeholder
okay password
authorized now here we should just be
able to we should just be able to log in
no authorize credentials user
what do I need to return
your endpoint this okay
we have user data return it could not be
retrieved what what is what's supposed
to be in this user object
like what is in there
is it just
something
like
like what's there this one okay good
user name email image huh okay
um
all right how about we just return
foreign
I'm that dumb
um
I don't know
are we doing authentication as a way to
deal with both well we we just want to
um
so authentication is is a
used for multiple things so one is yes
to deal with Bots the other one is also
to make a leaderboard uh to reward
people that provide a lot of data so we
give him some some swag or something
like this um
obviously the the fame of being a top
prompt contributor to open Assistant
will will be forever
forever valuable uh so
um
well oh I can I can just look it up I
can just look it up
what it needs
that is great thank you
so I will user
interface user extends default user
default user has this
okay
that's fair
so an ID a name email an image
optionally
so let's call it for an ID
a
name
with the username
no
no not happy
the expected time type
what's the problem
foreign
do I need to return some promise or
something
string it's a string ID is a string okay
ID
like this
now it's happy very good very good
providers push it push the provider yes
all right does this already work I'm
pretty sure it doesn't so we still need
to go to the sign up page here
and
um
sign in with email
providers
let's see what do we push it as
providers push Discord
credentials name credentials
Discord
yep but okay
well how how do I how do I
so here it just says Discord provider
right
how do I access that now
to understand that they probably gather
user interactions for further training
data but if you'd have a stop button
that would be a good marker something
went really wrong I guess
whether ionic actually has eyes
that will never
find out
um yeah how do I how do I access this
providers it just has providers no
push email
push Discord push credentials
what if I have multiple credentials
providers this is
credentials
credentials config
type credentials
I don't know
so I'll just I'll just try
I'll just try
providers where is it does this sign in
get called
um
let's go to references
go to references
nowhere
ah I see that's the the page
providers get providers
I can't really do more than that I'll
just
I'll just try this
and
I'm not sure which console this would
actually be printed is this server or
client side
we're just going to have to find out
so here is the console
foreign
so what
default client-side
cool thank you
we'll just put the providers here
Rush
can't you keep a list of JWT token
switch between them yes I want to make
it really easy for a newcomer
to get into this
so there's email
and that's it
that's it
our so some like
we we're missing something no
we are missing something
where
we need to somehow so API off
here we have providers
we put it here
we
sum is there something of layout no
I prefer the links rating
setup tests middleware
no
Styles that's not it next config no
DS Tailwind
nope
none of this
delegate this task
yeah but what else should we do now
sign in as a client-side component
if we set the environment you are thank
you thank you
thank you thank you
I was too dumb to do that let's before
we said it let's do the good old always
true
refresh
providers
providers credentials
yes
ah
cool okay so
um
yeah now we need to I guess render that
somehow excellent thank you
thank you satvik
very kind I would have I would have
looked around for another 15 minutes or
so at least before I would have gotten
that so it is actually called
credentials right
um
so yeah
um
we'll we'll copy that
here
credentials
on click
input
this should be this should be a form no
now I'm not sure what's this what kind
of element is this
chakra
um
UI
form is there a form
because I for sure want this to submit
whenever
enter is pressed
form control
forms
forms
input
I mean
ultimately I
input input
input
so they don't appear to have a custom
form element
so I'll just make like a regular form
I hope I hope that's fine
um
what's a stack oh okay
there we go form
good excellent good is new
um color scheme gray on click no is
disabled false
um
we'll say
on submit console
debug hello
and then we'll make the button of I hope
that's working
type submit
let's try
what's this nope
yeah okay
so the top one we the top one should be
ours that we just made
wrap it in a form control
um
well that worked
it worked
do I need to wrap it in a form control
because form
control form label
is the form control if I just if I want
like the label and all
like it all going together but
foreign
this should be fine no
I think this is fine
if not then
helpful people can can can uh yeah
do that
um
on click sign in with email let's make
in with
um debug
credentials
how do I interact with that
so
email element do is that is this the
good
is this the good way to do it with refs
or should I somehow like obviously
there's the event and I need to do
I need to prevent the fault here
um but is is it a good way to get the
values out of the event or out of refs
or put them in state
um
Supernatural so on submit we have right
here
um sign in with debug credentials
and we probably don't want an envelope
um
what's that
react icons F A okay
all right which ones do we have F A
what's f a
h
okay
font awesome that's fa
so debugging what's a good symbol for
debugging
the Canadian flag they're always a bit
buggy
how about
a wrench a bug yeah why not
is the bug yeah okay
that's funny
nice okay
um
maybe we can like superimpose like a
stop and the bug
so
um let's Trace that and that's also
import uh a bug
oh
two commas
three three compress commas
all right
excellent so we now have a bug icon
which which should show up here I've
this MacBook is
stressing over streaming this is it's
crazy
uh continue with debug user
I should probably not even have a
password
like just just the user would be fine no
um
so
username
yes ref
user
name
um
let's make a ref
um debug username
L2
to keep with the style that
other people people better suited than
me have provided so this implicitly has
an any type okay
what does copilot say
copilot is smarter than me
I don't know typescript I just do
whatever copilot says I should do
so let's go back to this auth here and
see what uh we should provide
as so in providers
um
what should we provide
for credentials so in credentials yes we
get that await
loser
um
type
credentials
required
authorize yes
but what do we need to to submit
mm-hmm
sign in
okay
so just sign in
with the Callback URL
okay why not and probably
probably the the credentials now so
username
would be
that
I think so I think that'll work out
will work out fine
now we need to go back to here and just
remove the password because that's kind
of useless
we just need a username
typescript is totally great I know I
know typescript is great I've just never
done it I've just always use copilot
it's it's really in like I would have
not guessed that I don't know three
years ago or so how
amazing co-pilot could be because I've
I've long been using you know AI
assisted coding tools like tab 9 and so
on and I was always a big fan of them
but then copilus is another jump
and that's it's just crazy
this is what people were scared of no
I'll read it I'll read it back and I'll
check I can I'm I think I'm confident
enough to check
um to see that what it's doing makes
sense but I don't know by heart you know
how do I this and that in next auth or
something like this and for that
co-pilot is really cool
so here we have a test user
let's see
and we are logged in
yes look at that account settings
doesn't work yet probably there is no
name here but we are in and that's what
counts
now let's make that a bit more pretty
shall we
um so currently the login page
is
what's this
you're already using a pop over button
but only pop one pop-up okay so this is
a bit too close together well we should
probably probably I'll hear it this
spacing what if we uh up that to like
five
barely
barely does something what if we remove
this form
does it do better
no okay so it's not the fact that we
have a form here although that could
probably
no I think that's
so
let's leave it with the with the
the five it's we could even it could
even benefit from a six here
yes that's better
all right
um now maybe
let's just outline this
and say
that
because
I don't I want to make sure this is this
is for debugging
um order
um
I'll make sure that's
clearly visible that this is for
debugging
yes
okay and what if we also here had
Maybe
a span that says
debug
foreign
something like this
now let's make that orange as well
ah
text Orange
let's make it like this a bit darker
or is that brighter no
it's more orange you're more orange
and let's make this here relative and
let's make this here
um
absolute top zero left zero
okay
actually but
how does this look
not too bad
it's probably wonky making this
inside but
then on top
but it doesn't it doesn't wonk up the
whole rest of the layout right because
this here is
this stack thing and otherwise this
would be a stack I guess I could make
this a its own thing I could bring the
form in make this the outside
um
I guess I could
for this being debugging it's it's it's
quite a bit
well but no but then I
ah
ah
I'm not sure what the stack thing oh the
stack is a okay it's like a diff with
with styling
um
I'm just gonna keep it that way
it doesn't need to be pretty because
it just needs to be
there are multiple formatters
one of them should be configured okay
configure
per tier
excellent
and what's also what we should do is
there should be a component somewhere
that's the Avatar is that this one so
account settings email so this is what
shows
here right
um
yeah
so
display name will do
session user name or
session user email
and we'll put that here
now if we log in like test2
sorry I haven't read chat in a while
Tailwind yes
where are the other videos of you
working on this I'd love to follow along
I guess I can put the other one on I'll
have to watch it back this one I haven't
said anything stupid which is good
um
how gpd's Copa the code assistant
compare in terms of accuracy quality I'm
not sure I've not programmed with chat
I've obviously asked it some stuff but
I've not productively coded with it
um
yeah
doesn't have as much knowledge as
co-pilot yeah I can I can imagine that
perhaps a debugging Banner
yeah
um
yeah I guess we could we could push this
um to to Eternity Center it on the line
really it kind of looked kind of looked
okay
ah you mean you mean moving okay yes I
know what you mean that's actually smart
yes we can do that that would look very
pretty I agree but why don't we have the
display name quite yet here
um
um
okay
um
let's log the user here
come on
but I've
MacBook slow MacBook slow
very slow
very good
okay name
yes
here we have name
name
name
hidden
it showed the email before did I
hallucinate
did I hallucinate that
I hallucinate the fact that over up here
it showed the email oh no okay ah large
okay obviously
foreign
go on
yes there we go
there we go
nice okay now let's take care of the
let's take care of that form I like that
idea
so that's the sign up
um where do we have it salute so maybe
like this
to just make it like on the line yes so
but we need to push it away a bit
let's
this
if we're really if we're really in it
we can make it aligned exactly with the
probably we can't
but
how about this
yeah and now
white background
yeah
yeah
okay I need some padding
um
that looks sweet
that looks nice
okay
I'm not too unhappy with this
very pretty
very pretty
Okay so
I guess that makes
a good commit
didn't need to do much
um
yes oh we could also change the readme
of the website
um
to document the process
getting everything up and running
how about here
using
debug
user
um
if you want
to
wait
you can use the
workflow
run npm the run and now we need our
we need our
thing where is it
by the way this thing is called I'm not
sure if you even see that
um
uh it's called Mackie it's a it's a key
uh a clipboard history
one of the best things ever
I guess we can hear
no
here
yes
debug fake users ah
we should also remove that
good better
[Music]
um
equals true
let's say one
true
what not
we should we should probably try that
out you know
uh
we should try this out before we
recommend other people do that
it'd probably be good if we did
oh oh oh also
I think if we set this to false it still
works
I think what we need to do is we need to
convert it to a Boolean
just my limited experience with
JavaScript
so that works but if we set it to false
I'm fairly confident
that would still
give me
the form
we need to actually make it to a Boolean
let's search for that
no too booly in this one
that one that one's pretty good no
or this one
because that's way newer
pull in
go into true
yes equivalent to false yes because that
has it has a lot of downloads what about
the other one a million downloads
a thousand downloads but probably this
one
when I say this one
okay Boolean
so
look
see the form is still there because
essentially it's a string that says
false which is true
surprise you don't use chat GPT it's
still kind of clunky you know copying
stuff around copilot is really good I
think they I think they feed the file
names and structures as well into
copilot because it's it's very good I'm
not exactly sure what they do but it's
quite good
um okay so let's say do we have it
already
okay
package do we have a Boolean
no
let's do that
okay Boolean
good
um
well now we can
I first wanna
do this
so the issue is how how best to do this
right with with settings and stuff like
this
um because technically I'd have to every
single time
uh that I import or that I use the
setting I'd have to convert it to a
Boolean right there which is I think a
bit
you know I'd rather convert it once
but for now for now what we can do is
go ahead and
use it oh we were on the correct page
um
yep
if that
so here we need Boolean
import
Boolean from Boolean
yes
back
all right
good
so now compiling
we have seen this we should no longer
see it
we still see it
no
what does mean replication in this
context it means that we're going to try
to do the same thing
that's it
um good so if we now do true we should
see the form
and switch back refresh
foreign
yeah I know but you know it does all of
these things like you know true true
true T yes on
one the number one
and it does all of these two Falls which
is more important right so
yeah
so and we see it excellent cool
um
yeah that is that
okay let's continue in the readme
and we have a bit of a preview here
no that's that was the the split Let's
Fold that in and get
a preview
you can use the following workflow
foreign
[Music]
use the
log in button the top right
to
go to the login page
you should see
a section
for debug
enter
any
user
username you wish
you will be
logged in as that user
good
so now let's make a commit
all right
um
yep yep
creates
created uh
debug
provider
what are you making
um I am making open assistant
which is an GPT like thing
foreign
the commit takes a while because next
lint takes a while
staged we just have changes
pre-commit
let's go
yeah yeah no
foreign
it's it's in the there's a there's a
should be a black box somewhere here I
guess
um are you planning on watermarking the
output why no
no
watermarking
that's dumb anyway
now I mean it's
it it can't work like it can work if
your output is an image you can encode
into some pixels something
um
you could also
you could also store some hash of
everything you've ever produced right
and then you could sort of and and you
could
kind of prove that
you already had it at some point like by
putting the hash on the on the chain on
the on the blockchain
but you you cannot
Watermark
linguistic output because who okay
can I I'm not sure how to do
um
there's no way to Watermark linguistic
output like what are you gonna gonna do
I can always say no I came up with that
right unless you have like a hash on a
blockchain that proves that you have
produced that but then you could also
just save stuff in a database and have
the government believe you or something
like this right
um there's no no method of watermarking
language as far as I'm aware of right
what is Scott Aronson doing for opening
I'm not sure but
I'm not sure but
it's not like just think about it for a
second you can't
you can't like like no
uh
yeah
maybe I'm maybe I'm stupid right maybe
it's like I don't get it but
it doesn't seem like it's it's possible
credentials provider
um
if
is set
um
next of is created that let's One log in
with an R
username
this
simplifies the
experience for new
who just want
to AG create a UI
opponent
okay let's do that create pull request
foreign
I don't know yet maybe gptj or something
um
yeah I'm gonna need to to open a web
browser vs code gets too cluttered
um reviewers are assigned
this
yes yes yes
I think we're good
I think we're okay reviewers
automatically assigned
surely AI models like GPD prefer some
words
yeah you can always you can build there
or open air detector models that work
quite well yes but it's always a
statistical thing it's never it's never
a proof because I as a human could
always say no no I came up with that
right unless you have actually
posted itself somewhere before like you
posted it I don't know on the blockchain
even some website like you posted it on
Facebook I don't know if that piece of
text already exists you know a week ago
then
um people will have trouble believing me
that I just came up with it yesterday
right because it's quite unlikely
um
however
if that doesn't there otherwise you just
have like a statistical indication like
well it looks like it came from a
language model will what do you even say
because we don't even have access to the
weights we can we're essentially left
with taking open ai's word for it again
right so either I don't see what's the
difference like because right now if
they were to come and say well we
produce this piece of text we just have
to take their word for it right and if
they say well this has a statistical
Watermark it we just have to say their
word that take their word for it so
I don't see that in a in a picture you
can change a bunch of pixels right so
that it's it's doesn't to human human
doesn't bother you can change a bunch of
pixel to actually recognize it and you
can do that in a way that's robust to
even Visual distortions and so on like
like content ID hashes and stuff like
this exist uh but with language is way
harder because what are you gonna do
change a bunch of words like that
doesn't make sense because you're gonna
change the piece of text right
um
so
yeah you sound like a chat but
yeah so I don't see I don't see I don't
see the water marking unless I'm like
not thinking of some some technique but
if you just from the text
like just having a piece of text and
then just from the text being able to
determine as an outsider with no access
to like secret information or so as an
outsider maybe with the access of a
public key but as an outsider to be able
to confirm yes this was produced by that
language model that's that's going to be
like impossible if yeah as I said one
method would be to just post whatever
they produce post the hashes somewhere
like build some some Merkel tree or so
so you can quickly verify but that's not
watermarking that's just storing the
text you don't change the text I don't
see how they're going to change the text
that's it that's my take on it
um
proven that Google is already not
indexing AI content from chat GPT it I
don't I don't see
like obviously they're not going to
scrape japt website or maybe they have
even maybe Google actually has
classifiers on what they index and and
what they don't Index right
but that has that there's more again
that's a statistical thing it's all this
text is likely to come from a chat model
and not from a human that you can never
have a proof for that
um like by definition as chat models get
more and more capable they'll sound more
and more like humans uh
you know imagine five years ago you
could tell when a picture was created by
some sort of a gan or so and nowadays it
like gets pretty easy like oh the eyes
the the you know papilla is not
perfectly rounded stuff like this
will it have the restrictions and
limitations like chat GPT has no no
restrictions no I mean obviously so I
mean
there is an argument to be made for
example there is this effort
um there are various efforts around
stable diffusion to sort of make
all-encompassing stable diffusions
including material that is like not safe
for work and to even tune and tune the
model to that there are certainly
applications right but you could argue
that a model is actually even more
useful when it has certain exclusions
like it actually excludes not safe for
work stuff because this Way businesses
for example can also rely on it in part
to do certain things right so it would
be
it would be less of a restriction more a
consideration of usefulness now that
being said it would obviously be the
most useful
like the intermediate step is to have
multiple models that do multiple things
it would be the most useful if the model
could do everything but you could easily
instruct it in given situations not to
do something like you could have some
stable diffusion model that you tell you
know I I know you could do all these not
safe for work but please you know right
now I'm trying to display some product
offerings to customers please no Gore
know this no adult content and so on
that I think that's that would be the
dream ultimately because that's most
like most like humans like all of you
are perfectly able to to swear and to
talk inappropriately yet in a
professional context you you hopefully
mostly choose not to do that and I
believe the most you know the the best
path forward will be to essentially
endow our models with the same things
with the same
the same abilities to essentially have
capabilities but then be able to be
instructed not to do something
that's my take all right this was this
was a code I'm not sure what we what we
should do I don't have like five minutes
left
um yeah so I'll I'll just hang around
and look at my pull request maybe some
maybe maybe something happens you know
thank you too thank you
lucaspar
hooray
um but yeah it's it's very exciting uh
what I think I think open Assistant if
the open source Community pulls together
and if we if we do that
um
we could have really capable thing
uh yeah if this becomes like something
like
um
there are a few open source projects
that then underpin the world and such a
unifying technology like you know an AI
assistant
um could be such such a thing like it's
completely viable that you have lots of
companies each with their own AI
assistance but it's also completely
viable that all of these assistants are
essentially based on the same assistant
and I think it's better if that same
assistant if that's the world we live in
it is an open Assistant uh much like we
all enjoy that most of the world's
operating systems are built around some
sort of Linux and not that Samsung has
their really very own operating system
and Huawei has their very own operating
system and so on
um I think the world's better off with
Linux as
as the underpinning
um
yeah and you could still Branch off from
that right every vendor takes whatever
Android it makes it a bit their own
um what's your plans on hosting the
finished product well as I said it
should be you should be able to run this
yourself on consumer Hardware
um or to host it on like sagemaker
endpoint or something like this we plan
to make it small enough such that it is
actually
um
you know capable of of being
being run everywhere
but if we make it larger then we'll find
we'll find something
do you know about kosm by versus no I
don't
um
a 10 a 1660. I don't even I I don't know
much about gpus I have to be honest but
we what we want to Target is more like
something like a 30 90 or a 40 90 or so
high-end gpus but still consumer gpus or
maybe one
GPU that you rent in a data center but
not
at you know a thousand so maybe at the
beginning we'll only get it small enough
that you maybe need one machine with
four or eight gpus but then we saw what
happened with stable diffusion and in
stable diffusion people very quickly
discover tricks and and things to just
really bring down the memory
requirements and the speed and we we
believe that if we if we just get it
close to where it's runnable then people
will figure something out
um yeah
how can we distribute the training model
it seems massively distributed training
no I think we'll have we'll we'll be
fine finding sponsors for training this
um that's not the the big part here is
really the data collection So the faster
we are finished with the whole website
and Bot and and that the faster we can
go out and really tell people hey we
need data please interact
um please interact with the model uh you
know please provide some training data
we could also think of maybe paying some
people uh crowd work style or handing
out prizes things like this there's
going to be a leaderboard so that's
going to be the limiting factor not
necessarily the training the training is
going to be I believe fairly easy ish
let's see
um
yeah
let's see
um
favorite Swiss YouTuber it's a thank you
that that is an honor
um
gpga is Sixpence mode 6B model not gonna
run on consumer horror it is it it is
almost right almost you can a 6B if you
can't touch to 16 bit
it's it gets there
it's it fits into like 11 gigabytes or
something like this so not too bad
what are other projects trying to
replicate chat GPT I'm I'm not super
sure but I think there are some which is
good
um the more there I mean it's obviously
not good if there's too many because
people would rather band together but I
believe a couple so that we try a few
different approaches is definitely
healthy
gamified we'll try we'll try we'll try
to give people some rewards
um some cool rewards but then also you
know you we we have to make it so that
people actually enjoy giving good
answers and not just giving many answers
so
foreign
those who ultimately sponsor it will be
requested to be limited and censored as
the media well yeah but if we just
release it Creative Commons
what can they do
otherwise we won't accept sponsorship if
the sponsors as well you can't do this
you can't do that and text is a bit I
think text in that regard is a bit less
quote-unquote dangerous than something
like a stable diffusion because with
stable diffusion you can you can I think
rile up people more if you get it to
produce something
uh iffy whereas if you get it to produce
some like dumb text you could be like
well okay I have like I know I know some
teenagers who could have written that as
well but if you get stable diffusion to
produce some gory images or so it's like
uh you know the teenagers around the
block can't just do that but they they
can produce some insults so I think
people look uh even though the problem
is essentially the same
um I don't think the people will look at
the outputs the same way they will I
think we'll with open assistant and what
all the chat models people are much more
realistic in that the actual danger
comes from applying like the person who
then deploys the model to do some tasks
and not the model itself which is it's
it's uh it's I don't really follow the
logic of sort of blaming the model
itself or blaming or or seeking to to
censor the model itself can you please
give us a small demo of the app
things on my machine well okay yes
that's something we could do right do we
still have it running yes so I'm not
I've actually never gone through the web
workflow
um so I hope that's gonna work so you
you log in
um
here
I don't think we have most of the tasks
even implemented yet so if you have the
debug mode on then uh you log in with
some user
it will let you log in
and here are the tasks so this is rate a
prompt and output now let's see if
anything happens at all
what about the people who get triggered
well they triggered already
I'm an ER dock on shift we've been
trying to figure out how these gpd3 or
GPT nailed to pull from Rose's emergency
medicine or the internet book how do I
do this I I don't know
I don't know
you can't make it pull from some book as
far as I'm aware
you can only
you can only ask it things that it
already knows it will never be able to
look up some stuff
um
automatic prompt generation from the
Train Engine Azure servers which are
powerful servers we'll find like money
money is ironically not the problem or
compute isn't it's it's labor like this
programming labor to actually get the
things done get the bot done get the
website done and the labor of providing
the training data
so
okay this doesn't seem to so well the
goal would be the goal would be that you
have tasks here that you could do
for example you rank some output by the
assistant or something like this and
once you've done that
um you could you could do these tasks
here that will send it to the back end
what we did today was simply to make one
form for the login
uh yeah so
the you can find a lot of information on
the
um
Repository
right here where is it here there is an
ocean page that explains the high level
protocol
um so I have to open this in an
incognito window otherwise my notion
opens
uh this is just small small thing so
here is the high level architecture
so
what we developed today is on this
website
um
everything communicates with the back
end
so the back end gives you some tasks and
then you present that to the user and
the user does the task and sends that
back to the to the back end
um
that's the basic protocols that the user
asks for a new task the front end tells
that to the back and the back end gives
it a new task then the front end will
post that task to the user saying hey
user could you please I don't know
pretend you're the assistant
give a response to this prompt right
here at the same time the front end
acknowledges to the back end yes I've
actually told the user to do this task
uh then at some point the user will come
back and
um
at some point the user will come back
here
with something with their fulfillment of
the task and the front-end reports that
to the back and the backend needs to
make sense out of everything essentially
and yeses thank you and then the next
task starts so imagine we want to break
up the conversation between a user and
the assistant into like individual Parts
each part becomes a task that we give to
the user saying hey user here's a
conversation so far please give an
answer as if you were the assistant so
that's going to be done for the first
step right here of the plan here is the
plan the plan is first
it's the instruct GPT paper plan first
we collect human generated samples uh
using that we
um
we train in a supervised fashion second
one
Second Step will try to get ranking data
for a reward model third step will train
the reinforcement learning from Human
feedback and that's that
all right I need to leave but
thank you very much for being here if
you want to participate we are looking
for anyone who who can uh help who wants
to help and if you want to wait and then
play the assistant a little bit for the
supervised data that would also be
really cool I'll announce that at some
point
um yeah thanks for for being here I hope
you're having a wonderful
um few few slower days Wherever You Are
and that's that all right stream over
thank you very much